und jetzt schauen wir noch mal auf den
zweiten teil des beschlossenen
entlastungspaket der tank rabatt ist ja
nur ein teil teil 2 ist das 9 euro
ticket im öffentlichen nah und
regionalverkehr und das gilt ja nun auch
ab heute bundesweit ja die
verkehrsverbände melden einen
regelrechten run auf das günstige
bahnticket das ja im juni juli und auch
noch im august gekauft werden kann von
münchen bis flensburg oder sogar bis
nach sylt für unter zehn euro ist
wirklich gut und das wollen natürlich
offenbar auch viele machen auch wenn sie
dafür stundenlang unterwegs sind denn
das ticket gilt ja nur für den
regionalverkehr langstrecken sind also
nur mit vielen umsteiger halten zu
meistern dennoch die bahn rechnet jetzt
schon mit sehr vollen zügen
wir schauen zu unseren reportern die
natürlich auch in ganz deutschland
unterwegs sind karl keim ist in münchen
und charly walter ist für uns in hamburg
alle schauen wir erstmal lädst du dir
wie ist die situation am bahnhof
hauptbahnhof die ist entspannt muss man
sagen also es ist wohl der tägliche
wahnsinn der hier immer stattfindet aber
das crc die züge aus allen nähten
brechen also das platzen das ist nicht
der fall tagtäglich sind hier 450.000
menschen unterwegs am bahnhof sowohl nah
regional und fernverkehr
und dann sind es bei der s-bahn
840.000 passagiere die täglich die
s-bahn nutzen und ich kann die fragen
direkt mal weitergeben an sina die
polizist sie sind pressesprecherin der
bundespolizeiinspektion hier in münchen
können sie uns einmal die eindrücke
schildern die die bundespolizei ihre
kollegen
erleben die ja auch in den s bahn
unterwegs sind ja also ich kann da ihre
einschätzung nur teilen unsere kollegen
haben gesagt das befürchtete wenn man es
denn befürchtet hat chaos ausgeblieben
es ist einfach so viel los wie immer
aber der befürchtete besucher ansturm
hier am bahnhof der blieb eigentlich aus
wie kann man sich das erklären gibt es
dafür anhaltspunkte wie das sein kann
dass es doch dass das chaos ausgeblieben
ist ich denke in münchen ist ja einfach
der pendlerverkehr immer sehr gut
frequentiert
die meisten pendler die es ja gibt die
nutzen die öffentlichen verkehrsmittel
ohnehin ändert jetzt auch das neue euro
ticket nicht so viel unser fokus liegt
eigentlich mehr auf den kommenden
feiertagen pfingsten steht vor der tür
und wir beobachten da erstmal dann auf
den ausflugsverkehr der sich hier von
münchen in richtung naherholungsgebiet
startet das heißt man geht davon aus
dass die menschen die das neun euro
ticket nutzen vorwiegend dann aus
schlichter sind und gar nicht so die
menschen die pendeln genau also wir
haben ja hier viele
ausflugsmöglichkeiten in münchen und
umgebung die berge die anliegenden sehen
und das werden wir uns am wochenende
angucken und sind dazu auch verstärkt im
einsatz wie muss man sich das vorstellen
verstärkt im einsatz
mehr menschen bedeutet ja auch mehr
konflikte sehr wahrscheinlich oder auch
eine chance für taschendiebe die auch
immer gern einmal in bahnhofsnähe
unterwegs sind muss man sich das
vorstellen das ist dann eine armada von
polizisten hier in bayerns bahnhöfen
unterwegs ist nein so wird es nicht
aussehen also wir haben schon die ein
oder andere streife mehr die sich dann
auch nicht mehr am hauptbahnhof bewegt
sondern auch an den anderen
verkehrsknotenpunkten und vielleicht
auch an den ausstiegsmöglichkeiten hier
im landkreis münchen usw wo vermehrt
menschen sind ist natürlich auch immer
vermehrt potenzial da das was passiert
taschendiebstahl ist da ein punkt es
kann natürlich auch sein dass wenn züge
überfüllt sind und ist dazu konflikten
mit der bahn kommt dass wir dann da
einfach auch unterstützend eingreifen
aber das müssen wir erst noch sehen gab
es schon menschen die mit dem euro
ticket in den ic wollten und da
vielleicht rausgetragen werden mussten
also dafür ist vielleicht ein bisschen
früh aber solche fälle sind uns bisher
zum glück noch nicht bekannt genau das
war die schilderung von tina der
sprecherin der bundespolizei inspektion
hier in münchen ich kann dazu sagen als
autofahrer der natürlich mit dem auto
zum bahnhof gekommen ist es waren doch
mehr parkplätze in der innenstadt in der
innenstadt frei also das sind so die
ersten schilderung die aus münchen dann
werden neu dazugekommen ist auch laura
meinfelder die für uns in leipzig am
hauptbahnhof steht hallo herzlich
willkommen laura gehen wir aber erstmal
die angekündigt charly walter nach
hamburg charlie ist denn die lage
momentan bei dir der erste berufsverkehr
die ersten pendler sind wahrscheinlich
weg wie war es heute morgen und die
große frage die natürlich im raum steht
ist was wird über pfingsten dort
passieren ich meine gerade aus hamburg
der schweren natürlich alle aus richtung
ostsee nordsee wie wird das werden und
wie bereitet sich die bahn darauf vor
also wenn das was heute passiert ist so
die vorteile sind für die kommende
urlaubszeit und binden dann sind das
eine gute zeit und ich habe heute morgen
bereinigen noch ihm gesprochen der mir
mit dem zug gefahren sind die angekommen
sind losgefahren sind und da war der
frust so groß da haben züge ausgefallen
und verspätet gewesen man kann dann
sagen eigentlich alles beim alten
eigentlich alles wie immer bei der
deutschen bahn der hamburger
hauptbahnhof ist gerade
ohne ist überlastet also dass ein
bahnhof er immer mehr passagiere hat
mehr frage ist also eigentlich
verkraften handel soll ausgebaut werden
das passiert aber erst in den kommenden
jahren mehr als eine halbe million
menschen fahren täglich ab und deswegen
ist es generell immer voll und die leute
mit denen ich heute morgen gesprochen
habe sie haben mir gesagt dass ich noch
mal etwas voller waren also
charlie dankeschön auch an der für
dieses kurze lagebild gehen wir weiter
zu seinen feldern nach leipzig ist die
situation bei der ähnlich laura
frustrierte fahrgäste oder freut man
sich jetzt dass man einfach günstig
fahren kann
also die freude in sachsen war groß über
das neuen euro ticket im vorfeld bis
heute nacht 00 uhr wurden 88 1000
tickets verkauft 14.000 allein gestern
bisher sind diese 80.000 aber noch nicht
am hauptbahnhof in leipzig zu sehen die
situation hier ist eigentlich recht
entspannt
aber ich habe mit den sprechern der
verkehrsbetriebe gesprochen und auch mit
bahn-mitarbeitern spätestens zum
pfingstwochenende rechnet man mit dem
großen ansturm denn sachsen lockt ja mit
schön freizeitangeboten man kann das
neue euro ticket auch auf dem wasser
nutzen und zum beispiel 13 11 r nutzen
oder auch mit seilbahnen oder
dampfeisenbahn fahren spätestens zum
wochenende könnte sich das ganze drehen
und ordentlich ansturm auf die bahnhöfe
lostreten vielen dank für deinen
einschätzungen live aus leipzig danke
euch allen so das thema wollen wir
natürlich noch ein bisschen vertiefen
und zwar mit dem pressesprecher der
deutschen bahn achim stauß schönherr
strauß dass sie bei uns sind es also die
leute freuen sich auf dieses 9 euro
ticket ja schon im vorfeld sind
millionen tickets verkauft worden
allerdings kann man jetzt schwer
einschätzen wer wird dieses ticket jetzt
nutzen und auf welchen strecken wird es
dann genutzt wie hat sich die bahn
darauf vorbereitet das sind ja doch
relativ viele unbekannte in dieser
rechnung wir haben uns tatsächlich
vorbereitet mit vielen zusätzlichen
zügen die wir auf die gleise stellen 250
im nahverkehr noch mal zusätzlich aber
auch viele mitarbeiter werden eingesetzt
zusätzlich auf strecken die vor allem
touristisch interessant sind die lenken
die reisenden am bahnsteig die machen
service im zug sicherheitskräfte
verstärken die reinigung der züge also
wir tun das möglichste damit dieses
ticket erfolg wird sind sie erleichtert
dass heute erst mal das große chaos
ausblieb und können sie garantieren dass
es auch wirklich über pfingsten dann
alles läuft so werden heute wirklich
nichts kritisches erwartet wir freuen
uns darauf dass es jetzt diese
möglichkeit gibt so günstig bahn zu
fahren auch viele kunden neu für die
bahn und für die busse zu gewinnen das
ist eine riesenchance für den öpnv in
deutschland der ist in aller munde und
ich bin sicher dass wir auch den
reisenden ansturm auf manchen strecken
gut beraten die ist zweifellos da die
haben aber manchmal jetzt schon bei
schönem wetter auf ausflugs strecken
wenn dann alle noch ihr fahrrad
mitnehmen wollen also da sind auch ein
bisschen was gewohnt und fällt keiner
tipp wer jetzt an solchen tagen bei
schönem wetter fahren will auf
touristisch spannenden strecken
vielleicht das fahrrad erst am zielort
mieten allerdings muss man jetzt auch
sagen innerhalb sozusagen der einzelnen
bundesländer gab es da am anfang schon
ein bisschen sorge über dieses neuen
euro ticket ob man es tatsächlich
stemmen könnte und b auch was die kosten
angeht denn natürlich geben jetzt den
einzelnen ländern auch das geld wegen
der region also wegen der normalen
regulären ticketverkäufe verloren es
wird jetzt wieder ausgeglichen ist das
eine rechnung die ihrer meinung nach
tatsächlich aufgeht wichtige für uns als
db und dafür kann ich sprechen geht das
ganze auf der bund hat ja versichert
dass er da ausgleichsbeiträge zahlen
wird ich sehe wirklich hier mehr die
chancen als die risiken so dass das
finanzielle betrifft als auch die große
chance wirklich menschen auch wieder
fürs bahnfahren und fürs busfahren zu
begeistern die uns fällt auch während
der korona pandemie abhanden gekommen
sind und glauben sie also dass das noch
ein euro ticket dann tatsächlich auch
geeignet ist um die menschen langfristig
zum umsteigen zu bewegen oder ist das
jetzt vielleicht dann einfach nur eine
kurze welle und wenn das ticket dann
wieder aus ist im september da geht es
dann doch wieder auf die straße wir
haben in dem beitrag ja wirklich
glückliche kunden gesehen die im zug
nach süden fahren wenn wir die auch mit
einem guten angebot überzeugen dann
werden die auch wieder kommen auch wenn
das das ticket dann nicht mehr neun euro
kostet für den ganzen monat das ist
unser anspruch aber ich sage auch das
ganze ist ein logo es gibt keine
blaupause dafür wir alle werden jetzt
auch in den nächsten wochen sehr viel
dazu lernen und ich bin ganz
optimistisch dass wir auch langfristig
dafür menschen gewinnen es ist glaube
ich auch wenn es gut läuft und man sich
einfach wohl fühlt dann steigt man auch
langfristig um sie haben eben schon ein
paar tipps angesprochen also besser
nicht das fahrrad mitnehmen sondern
vielleicht dann vor ort am urlaubsziel
das fahrrad mieten haben sie denn sonst
noch tipps für alle die jetzt über
pfingsten verreisen wollen ja es hat
nicht schlecht antizyklisch zu fahren
also vielleicht nicht dann zu fahren
wenn man denkt ja alle anderen wollen
jetzt auch genau diesen zug nehmen
vielleicht auch bei fahrten in
ausflugsgebiet nicht den allerletzten
zug zu nehmen sondern kleinen puffer
einzubauen und einfach gegenseitige
rücksichtnahme in den zügen die hilft
immer und unsere zugbegleiterin
zugbegleiter sind auch entsprechend
informiert und werden die reisenden
kümmern ich glaube gemeinsam werben das
schaffen haben sie denn das gefühl dass
man jetzt obwohl man jetzt auch so viel
geld natürlich darin investiert dass man
das dann auch halten kann dass man
irgendwo die bahnreisenden auch auf
einem glücklichen
niedrigpreisigen vivo sozusagen erhalten
kann oder sehen sie sich dann irgendwann
gezwungen tatsächlich auch wieder
auszugleichen und die preise wieder nach
oben zu treiben wenn das ganze vorbei
ist darüber möchte ich wirklich noch
nicht spekulieren ich denke wir haben
auch ohne dass neun euro ticket ein
attraktives preissystem bei der bahn im
fernverkehr sowieso mit den vielen
sparpreisen super sparpreisen mit der
bahncard es kommt auch neben dem preis
auch aufs angebot an das ist ganz
wichtig ein zuverlässiges angebot wir
bauen das schien jetzt ja aus um noch
mehr fahrzeuge fahren zu lassen das ist
letztlich auch die voraussetzung dafür
dass wir die verkehrswende schaffen dass
wir wirklich mehr menschen fürs
bahnfahren begeistern für das
klimafreundliche bahn fahren eine frage
noch zu diesem verkehrs netzausbau das
soll in ganz großem umfang passieren
sehr viele wichtige strecken auch
gleichzeitig worauf müssen sich pendler
dann auch in diesem fall einstellen wird
es da das große chaos geben wie soll das
umgeleitet werden wir werden keine
alternative dazu das schienennetz zu
sanieren und stehen jetzt auch endlich
die finanziellen mittel des bundes zur
verfügung das zu tun das geht nicht ohne
wachstumsschmerzen ohne sperrung von
strecken und von bahnhöfen dann müssen
wir gemeinsam durch aber das ziel ist
natürlich hinterher besser zu sein mehr
kapazitäten anbieten zu können wichtig
ist aber für die fahrgäste auch für die
pendlerinnen und pendler alles was wir
ändern im fahrplan ist immer in die
fahrpläne langfristig eingearbeitet
es wird also niemand überrascht könnten
sie sich denn von ihrer seite aus
vorstellen dass neun euro ticket noch zu
verlängern es geht ja erst mal nur bis
august es ist gilt bis august die
sommermonate sind auch ein ganz guter
zeitpunkt dafür weil dort ja auch viele
wegen der urlaubszeit nicht in die
schule fahren nicht zur arbeit fahren
weil sie ferien haben da ist dann
dadurch auch wieder ein bisschen mehr
platz in den zügen und jetzt kommt so
würde ich erst mal darauf an aus zu
werden alle teilnehmer die ganze branche
ist ja sehr gespannt darauf was jetzt
passiert das wird man auch
wissenschaftlich auswerten und dann die
richtigen schlussfolgerungen ziehen
besten dank für ihren besuch heute hier
janas pressesprecher der deutschen
dankeschön